absolute chaos took place in kansas
over a republican elected official who
was apparently moonlighting as a
substitute teacher
and is accused of kicking a student as
we used to say
in the balls or in the balls as you know
who used to say
among all sorts of other wild and wacky
things i'm talking about kansas state
representative
mark samsel yes he's a republican
he filled in at wellsville high school
in wellsville kansas
last wednesday samsel represents this
very area
in the state legislature that includes
wellsville and the school
samsel apparently went bonkers trying to
push
what is a kind of pseudo-religious
agenda on the children he was berating
some of the teenagers
he was pleading with them to follow god
he was asking them about their
masturbation habits was demanding that
the children
make babies because it quote feels good
and claiming that a sophomore at the
school must be contemplating suicide
because they have lesbian parents
and then as if that's not enough things
really got
nuts for lack of a better term when
samsung
allegedly grabbed one student
pushed him against the wall attacked
another by invoking the quote wrath of
god
hitting him intentionally in the
testicles
and then inviting others in the class to
do the same
here is some of the rant which was
caught on video and audio
make babies who likes making babies that
feels good doesn't it
procreate he says encourage it
you haven't masturbated don't answer
that question i'm not gonna answer
you know thank you i told you not to god
doesn't god already knows enough
you're about ready to anger me i get the
wrath of god
do you believe me when i tell you that
god has been speaking to me
i could put the wrath of god on you
right now because that's what you're
telling me to do
you should run and scream because the
devil is
so who put together the bible multiple
stories from different people
it wasn't even just one actually this
one it was multiple different editors
tried to combine all the stories
while there were distractions
you know i had some pretty wacky
substitute teachers in elementary school
and middle school in high school
never anything remotely close to this
that's for sure
he has since admitted that he planned
his actions
but says he did nothing wrong i don't
know what that means
the 36 year old republican was arrested
on charges of alleged
misdemeanor battery already a lot of
people who saw the video saying there
has to be a felony in there
how is this only misdemeanors he was
booked into the franklin county adult
detention center
he's been released on a thousand dollars
bond now in case you were wondering the
superintendent ryan bradbury
said samsel will no longer be substitute
teaching in the school district
i'm curious how the kansas republican
party will respond to this they've
i've not heard anything from them at
this point some people wrote to me and
said you know david this is not really
about politics or religion this is a
psychotic break
this is merely a mental health incident
he just sort of happens to be obsessed
with things like
accepting god but there's really nothing
political here
i agree that this is not a stable and
well-balanced person there's no question
about it
uh beyond that there's there remain
questions
and in a later snapchat post samsung
reportedly claimed
that quote every little bit of it was
planned
to send a message about art mental
health
teenage suicide how we treat our
educators and one another to parents
and grandparents of wellsville so
i guess going to i the kids and i
we did this together uh to send some
kind of a message
a very strange way to send a message for
sure
and we will follow the court proceedings
and see what ultimately takes place
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation
because they're either dry or boring or
don't taste that good or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor monk pack
is completely different because monk
pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture and yet
they have only 140 calories
one gram of sugar and only two to three
net carbs perfect
for the low sugar or keto diet they come
in
fantastic flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
blueberry almond vanilla and the new
flavor
peanut butter i've been a fan for a long
time i always have them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i do
you get all your money back they also
now have a subscription feature which i
love it'll save you 10
on every order and it ships
automatically
you'll get 20 off when you go to
monkpack.com and use the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video